- I would like to walk down the red carpet
and have the interviewers talk to me,
about the choices that I made
creatively as opposed to,
"Hey, you're a female."
And be like "Yeah, and?"
(upbeat music)
Having been in a band,
I was recording things,
and they weren't coming out right.
And that was it,
I wanted to be in control
of what it sounded like.
- [Woman] Emily Lazar
is a mastering engineer.
- In it's most basic,
mastering engineer takes
either stereo, or multi-channel audio,
and prepares it for distribution.
Whether that be making it sound the best
on a piece of vinyl, on Spotify.
One mastering approach doesn't always work
for all of those different needs.
- [Woman] But she isn't
just any mastering engineer,
she is the first woman
to ever to be nominated
in the category of Best
Engineered Album Non-Classical.
- When that first Grammy
nomination where I was up
for the first woman,
for album of the year,
I was like completely in shock.
And so I started, you know, trying to look online,
to see if I could figure out
if that was actually true,
'cause it couldn't be, in my mind.
It just couldn't be.
- [Woman] Mastering the mastering industry
doesn't always save you
from the inevitable.
- Being female and being in audio
in the first place, was a complete oddity.
There's sexism, there's ageism,
there's all sorts of things that happen.
And we're in a culture now
where you can speak out.
I was not allowed, really,
to speak out before.
I also had situations where I had people
inject me into a situation
because I was a woman
and because they thought
that was a cool thing
to have a woman in there.
Which was also equally as despicable.
These things happened, and
I'm aware that they happened,
but they did not get my attention.
They did not suck me down.
And I always try to
inspire, not just women,
to follow their dreams.
I really believe that if you can see it
and make it happen, it happens.
And if you only see
all the negative stuff,
all the people who don't want women,
or don't treat you like
an equal or whatever,
then you're gonna spend your
life kind of focusing on that.
And I don't have time for that,
I don't have room for that.
I have wanted to make records,
I don't wanna talk about why I can't.
(uplifting music)